hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast make your clinical sequencing
count technical and content decision for
improved disease targeted panels
i'm rachel brown of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
we have a few important announcements
before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event
you can submit questions by typing them
in the q a box which can be found by
clicking on the green q a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem through
the green q a button lower left
i would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr sami amir
serves as director of the translational
genomics core at
partners personalized medicine and as
assistant director at the clia certified
lab for molecular medicine
he is involved in development validation
and reporting of clinical genetic
testing across a variety of disease
areas
with a focus on hearing loss
i will now turn it over to dr emmer for
his presentation
hello
uh thank you for the opportunity uh to
speak to you today
um
regarding our experience with uh with
clinical genetics panels
this is uh this slide just shows my
disclosures i am an employee of partners
personalized medicines lab for molecular
medicine which is a not-for-profit fee
for service clia genetic testing
laboratory we do testing on a variety of
disease areas including non-syndromic
hearing loss
cardiomyopathy
as well as
newton's syndrome and a whole host of
smaller genetic disorders
so in this talk i just want to really
share with you our experiences
in running these clinical genetic panels
on next generation sequencing and what
are kind of the things that we've
learned across the way or what are the
challenges that we've approached and
really i've bended here into two
different uh
major concepts that i'm going to be
talking about or covering in a little
bit uh some are the technical
considerations to think about which are
things um you know in trying to identify
variants making sure that they're true
variants uh and
and issues related to that and then the
other piece that's also related to
these clinical panels is the
interpretive and analytical challenges
that we've encountered um
and we'll talk about that in a little
bit
so these are just the the different
sequencing testing platforms that we've
used over the years in
our laboratory and we continue to use of
course uh everybody's familiar with
saying or sequencing it's known as the
gold standard um
and
then we moved to larger panels using
resequencing areas and now we're all
using next generation sequencing panels
um and here we're comparing these three
testing platforms on on several
parameters including target size cost
and turnaround time of course sanger
sequencing is is optimal for smaller
gene panels or one gene test you can do
it fairly efficiently fairly quickly
resequencing arrays allows you to expand
the number of genes that you can do at
once
and of course next generation sequencing
uh the the major uh contributor the
major advantage is that you can do many
number of genes across a large number of
samples all at once
and this is shown here by the target
size
the cost of saying your sequencing is
lowest when you're looking at a single
gene
um
you know if you're just sequencing a
single gene for one patient however
for when you expand to a large number of
panels a large number of genes or large
number of patients then next generation
sequencing is uh more advantageous and
can be cost effective if used in that
manner uh the turnaround time for a
single reaction when you're looking at
sanger sequencing it is much lower it's
one to two weeks uh resequencing erases
somewhere in the middle that's six weeks
and maturation sequencing as when those
when these slides were made it was seven
to eight weeks but as we all know with
the um
with the recent uh uh
advances in both of the reagents and the
bioinformatics this can be up to one
week nowadays so it's definitely
improved over over time
and now the advantage of next generation
sequencing that we've encountered is
that it can detect all types of genetic
variation and here we we show the
different types of the variations just
the screenshots from
different uh applications that we've
used it for so
here we use this is just a single single
nucleotide variant that we've used um
um this is a single variant that we've
used
this lower this lower one here shows a
indel that we've identified an intronic
uh region of a gene and it also can
do copy number variation as shown in
this plot here so
here we detected a
ush to heterozygous
two exon deletion or a homozygous
ashtray to exon deletion uh an
individual with the non-syndromic
hearing loss
uh the the sensitivity for smvs is very
high it's comparable to that of saying
or sequencing uh as well as the
specificity is very high it's a little
bit lower for indels
um it's a little bit harder to detect in
dells using a next-generation sequencing
and that is a
um
it depends on the size of the envel and
the location of the indel so if it's a
in a repeat region or if it's uh very
large then it might be more difficult to
detect these in those uh cmvs can be
detected and the way that uh
different labs do it is that they're
looking at
cmvs is is detected using the coverage
of a
region
um compared with the coverage of the
region from a different sample so you're
taking each one of these reads
essentially or the coverage at that at a
certain region and comparing it and
seeing whether that uh
whether the ratio would indicate that
there's a copy number loss or a gain uh
based on coverage metrics i don't want
to get into that too much but i do want
to tell you kind of the the issues that
have come that we faced as a result of
just using that approach to be able to
identify cnvs
so the sensitivity for copy number
variant detection is high
using our experience however what we
found is that also the specificity is
low so we're seeing a lot of false
positives and i'll show you a few on the
next page
so this is the output that we get from
copy number variants uh using our
algorithm or our software tool using
next generation sequencing data so
the the panel on the left shows a
heterozygous otoforlin
deletion of 47 exons of this gene and
the right panel shows a uh homozygous
two exon deletion in dash to aegin which
i showed earlier
however you're also seeing these small
i'm going to try to point them out these
small
you know calls that are shown here are
these truly gains or
losses of other loci within this gene
what we follow up testing confirmed that
there is a high
um
there is a high false positives
especially with single exon
calls and you can see that there's a lot
of kind of noise associated with this
and when we followed up on all these
single exon calls we identified them as
false positives so
it does still have a low specificity and
you do need a secondary assay to confirm
uh cnv calls
the other piece is that you know these
two plots look really nice uh however
the success of
the algorithm to work and to be able to
make these calls is dependent on
batch effects so every single batch
maybe may behave differently and there's
a lot of bench
process so the hybridization of the ngs
captured has to be
done properly and has to be uh
very
efficient for it to work um
you know we find often that that that
hybridization may be sufficient to call
smvs and to call indels however the the
if the cmv calls is too noisy to make a
call and we end up failing the
the cmv caller while passing the smv and
the sequence detection
so uh we use uh next-generation
sequencing panels uh for
uh all our disease areas this is the
this just shows you the list of genes
that we use it for our non-syndromic
hearing loss and
hearing loss related disorders gene
panel
this is a 70 gene panel 70 gene targeted
panel
that includes genes associated with
non-syndromic hearing loss but it also
includes genes that are associated with
the
um
syndromic hearing loss in syndromes that
appear initially as
uh as non-syndromic hearing loss so the
initial presentation or the first
presentation that the physician may see
is non-syndromic hearing is hearing loss
and then other features may develop over
life
and so i just wanted to share with you
uh results from a small cohort uh
from this panel that shows sort of our
experience with this
um and uh from a cohort of 87 positive
individual original individuals with
hearing loss that were run on the other
genome
panel there's two things to really note
from this slide
one is that
the genes that are causing hearing loss
in this cohort are many so there is
definitely genetic heterogeneity in this
cohort and that that or genetic
heterogeneity that causes hearing loss
and so it's not enough to just go after
a single gene it's really important that
we uh broaden our uh
tests so that they include a large
number of genes so as to be able to
identify the positive variant the second
piece to really uh think about is uh
shown in this uh
um table down here which illustrates
that the causative variants within these
genes are also broad so you can have
mis-sense variants you can have nonsense
variants you can have
small deletions or insertions that cause
hearing loss but you can also have a
large number of positive variants or
copy number variants about 20 percent of
from our cohort 20 of individuals
had a copy number variant that was
causative to their hearing loss which
which shows not uh not only how
important it is to be able to detect to
carry out testing but also to be able to
detect copy number variants in these
individuals because we may be missing a
large number of uh copy number there a
large number of positive variants if we
don't include copy number variant
detection within our next generation
sequencing
platform
so to be able to do cnv detection we
know that it's there's a high false
positive rate we know that uh um
that it's also not it's not doesn't work
for every dash so how can we supplement
or how can we make sure that we do cover
cmvs in in whatever testing strategy
that we use so there's uh often what
we've what different labs have done
including ourselves is that we've used
secondary assays for confirmation of
cmvs so if we detect the cmv on the uh
maturation sequencing platform we might
follow up with an mlpa or digital drop
of pcr to confirm whether that variant
is true or not
another option would be to supplement
with a different cmv detection platform
if the if we find that the false
positive rate or that the
fail rate for the cmv portion of the ngs
assay is too high then we might opt on
you know not doing cnvs on the ngs
platform but uh carrying out a uh a
supplementary assay next to the ngs data
to make sure that we cover um
the
uh to make sure that we're covering copy
number variants i know a lot of labs are
doing that uh
you know they're offering exome
sequencing on on ngs which covers a
sequence nucleotide uh single nucleotide
variants as well as indels but they're
also carrying out
a race each external level of a cgh for
example to be able to detect cmvs on a
separate platform
so here i want to just give an example
of
one of the reasons that's very critical
to being able to identify copy number
variants in hearing loss
and how we kind of come up with a
secondary assay to approach or to to
address the copy number variant issue
essentially there's a region in upstream
of gjb2 a very common gene that's
associated with the non-syndromic
hearing loss uh which is subject to
large number of uh
deletions so there's two common
deletions that are shown in this uh in
this figure and both of these deletions
lie upstream of uh gjb2 located here
um and
these deletions essentially cause
expression a repression of expression of
gdb2 thereby causing hearing loss
our normal ggb2 strategy is to be able
to sequence uh gjb2 and we have a couple
of gel assays that can detect one of
these two deletions the more common ones
so we can't detect both of these in the
method that we're doing it now um
alternatively we also have probes that
cover this entire region from gjb2 all
the way to this uh
upstream
gene cry i can see it on my but you know
upstream of gjb2
and uh
uh
that cover the entire region that's
right using probes designed to be able
to identify using the ngs data
however you have to run the ngs data
the ngs platform to be able to detect
the variance so this is kind of the
um
the design that we've used so the miscap
target or the ngs targets each one of
these right here represents a
um
represents probes that we've designed
to be able to cap to hybrid capture
these regions that lie upstream of the
gjb2 gene so we're able to detect these
deletions
um
and
while those two up here in the in the
first graph
or the first figure represent the most
common deletions there are other
deletions that have been identified that
are also important to be able to detect
um and so what we've designed designed
are a number of ddpcr probes
that essentially five ddc ddpcr probes
that sit in one of the several
wells they sit outside as well as inside
the deletion
regions
and
using ddpcr probes were able to run the
cmv
assay without having to to rely on ngs
data which may fail or may cause lots of
false positives in addition gjp ii
represents or
variance affecting gjp2 represent 25 of
all
uh variants that cause non-syndromic
hearing loss so
some labs may opt to do gjb2
sequencing first using sanger sequencing
because it is cheaper for one gene
and then reflects to uh non natural
panels
if the gjb2 singer sequencing test was
negative
and so you wouldn't be able to pick up
all these deletions unless you're
running the ngs panels
so what we did is now we're running the
gjb2 test
and we're using the ddpcr assay as a
way to be able to detect the cmvs and
that allows us to do two things
we mitigate the failure rate of the ngsc
and v assay ddpcr has a lower failure
rate than the mgs cmv assay and so that
way we're able to capture these uh
these copy number variants fairly
efficiency
as well as the second piece is that the
ngs assay is much more expensive than
the cost to just run the ddpcr and here
we just show what the prices from our
lab of the two different tests so for to
be able to run the ngs platform whether
you're just doing it for copy number
variation or if you're doing it to
capture sequence variation as well as
the ngs variation this costs anywhere
from 2500 to almost 4 000
while the cost of to run the bdpcr assay
is under a thousand dollars
so there's other limitations of ngs
panels are also
not associated for two
to
cmvs this includes gc rich regions these
are regions that are difficult to
capture
using the current reagent technology
and those are issues with as i mentioned
earlier being able to identify larger
indels being able to look at repeat
expansions and the issue of pseudogene
contamination due to high homology so
there's a gene of interest that has a
pseudogene that is
that shares high homology what that gene
of interest it's difficult to kind of
identify what are variants that are seen
in that gene come
from that gene or if they come really
from the pseudogene and we'll talk a
little bit more about that a little bit
the
issues of large indels as well as repeat
expansions we're slowly overcoming that
with longer read technology as well as a
better bias advanced analysis to be able
to pick up those things
so talking about uh so i want to look at
focus on pseudogenes and the issue
related to that and a great example of
that is uh
is the sdrc gene which is one of the
genes that also has
contributes to non-syndromic hearing
loss
about 10 to 50 percent of all
individuals with nuts and german hearing
loss have a deletion in this sdrcg
um but the issue with being able to test
for the sdrc gene lies in the fact that
this gene which is located here
uh has a
pseudogene which is located upstream of
this gene
that shares about
99.8
homology
with with the with the actual functional
gene and this includes exons as well as
entrons of that gene
and uh
like i mentioned before however
we need to be able to capture this to
really uh increase the clinical
sensitive sensitivity of the assay since
many individuals
who have hearing loss have
variance or copy number variants in this
gene
so this this diagram here up here
illustrates the uh
the gene this part of the gene which is
shown in black
is actually at 100 homology the uh
the three prime end of the gene has
lower homology but it is still very high
so to be able to uh
so to be able to
capture this gene if we run normal
standard sequencing of each individual
exon or if we do
um
if we do regular capture and ngs what
happens is you get
uh outputs like these two right here
which is pseudogene contamination
at any particular position so it's not
clear if the variant comes from the
pseudo gene or if it comes from the
actual functional gene
and to mitigate that one solution that
we found is to run long-range pcr the
entire
region using primers that are unique
specifically to the
uh
to that gene
um and that basically bordered the gene
from the phyton and the three prime end
and then subsequently you can either run
it using sender sequencing or here we
show that we're running it using ngs so
you can literally take that amplified
long range pcr fragment and throw it in
onto the my seek or the high seek or
into
whatever capture you've done initially
or you can also just run it as a as a
separate sender assay and this way we've
been able to identify true variants in
the sdr's gene and eliminate the
pseudogene contamination those genes and
we published our results in a journal of
molecular diagnostics shown here
the other issue associated with sdrc you
also see issues with being able to
identify copy number variants and this
is again important for sdrc because
there's a large number of variants
in sdrc specifically copy number
variants as seen in hearing loss cohorts
in the top panels up here
you can see what a non-pseudogene gene
cmv output would look like so a
heterozygous deletion would be near the
negative one on this log2 scale a
homozygous deletion would be down here
at the minus
2 or negative 2 on the log 2 scales and
this is typical of what you're seeing
however because of the pseudogene
contamination it also
affects
the detection of cnvs and being able to
call the zygosity of that cnv so
essentially this is meant to kind of
illustrate
what's going on with the pseudogene
instead of having two copies of each
gene you have two copies of the
of the gene but you also have two copies
of the pseudogene and when you lose
in a homozygous deletion you lose two
copies of the gene but you still have
two copies of the pseudogene therefore
it looks like a heterozygous deletion
for regions that are high in homology
and so when you run the sdrc on this gap
you see this kind of waterfall
this waterfall shape or this waterfall
looking
graph
regions that are up here
were shown within the arrow are regions
of high homology and regions down here
are regions of that gene that have low
homology and are more
uh
are more representative of the
homozygous deletion that you're seeing
that gene
so again to be able to while this kind
of you know it flags the the cnv that
yes it does exist in your sample a
follow-up test using unique primers uh
via ddpcr
is needed to be able to verify whether
this is a heterozygous deletion or
homogeneous deletion and what regions
does it does affect in the strcg
so just to kind of summarize what we've
been talking about in terms of technical
challenges
the
it's important to have secondary assays
to confirm variants
we
we use currently sanger sequencing for
single nucleotide variants and we've
done mlp or digital droplet pcr for cmvs
and it's important to consider
supplementary assays for variant
protection and this is true especially
for copy number variants as we know that
mgs technology is not exactly where it
needs to be for clinical copy number
variant detection and
so for high homology regions for single
multiplied variance as well as uh copy
number variance we use
uh long range pcr for the single
nucleotide variance and we're using
ddpcr or other methods for
um
for a cmv detection
okay i want to shift a little bit uh in
terms of uh what we're talking about now
so we've looked at technical
considerations in running these clinical
genetic panels
i also want to talk about the
interpretive and analytical challenges
that uh
that we've encountered while expanding
onto the ngs platform adding more genes
and running them across large cohorts
and there's really two major
contributors
that uh
that we faced or two major challenges
that we faced and the the the challenges
come from two things the large number of
novel and rare variants that we've
identified
in these cohorts and
the growing number of genes on ngs
panels so in the slide a few slides ago
i showed you 70 gene panel for hearing
loss well just last week or two weeks
ago we launched a new
uh
uh non-syndromic hearing loss panel that
has 87 genes and so and the number of
genes that physicians are asking for
that researchers come up with in terms
of
their association with disease is ever
expanding and
more so we're even moving from the
paradigm of looking at one disease
and now we're moving towards the exome
so we're looking at all 30 000 genes
or the medical exome which is 5000 genes
but it's just an expanding number of
genes that molecular geneticists are
having to look at to try to identify and
assess variants that are related with
certain gene uh with a certain disease
and certainly this is one of the biggest
bottlenecks in being able to uh provide
a test with fast turnaround time
so this figure illustrates the number of
variants that our lab encountered over
uh 15 000 pro bands that were run here
and this is for all disease areas that
we've looked at including hearing loss
cardiomyopathy
myopathies
marfan syndrome etc um and the important
thing to see here is that
it's shown by this first uh
by the by the you know first column here
which is the majority of the variants
that we've seen whether they were
pathogenic whether there were variants
of unknown significance um
they were all seen in one individual or
one family so these events that haven't
been seen before haven't been reported
anywhere
and we're having to go in there and try
to based on the information that we have
which is very little to try to classify
these variants and to try to understand
whether they are related to disease or
not
there are some variants that are very
common that are shown here that we know
about and are easy to classify but
for the majority of variants it's
they're unique and they are rare and uh
obviously you can imagine that every
variant requires uh scrutiny and uh um
lot of time is spent to try to interpret
those variants
now the other piece that complicates
this is that
the number of genes that are being
discovered and that are associated
with disease is increasing so this is uh
this graph is uh taken from information
from hemd the human gene mutation
database and you can see that every year
a larger number of genes are deposited
into this database
and are associated with with disease
now the question is how are these
how are these
genes associated with certain diseases
what is what is the evidence that is
used uh to kind of promote and to kind
of support those gene disease
associations and uh here's the list of
on the left is a list of different
databases
and sources that we use we look at when
trying to determine whether a gene
disease association does exist now
the issue with this is that a lot of
these databases they deposit information
they don't check the veracity or they
don't check the level of evidence of
these gene disease associations so it's
not always
it may be one paper one publication
looking at one family somewhere
that
creates or that
indicates or suggests that a gene
disease association however is it
truly there that that remains to be seen
and it's the job of the genetic
laboratories to look into that to
determine whether these gene disease
associations truly exist or not
so the best way to kind of demonstrate
the issue of the gene disease
associations is with the case that i'm
going to show here so
part of our original 70 gene panel we
included two genes that are shown down
here gjb6 and myo1a and i'll be talking
about these uh in detail
um
however so we'll start with the with
with this case
it's a seven month old male who
presented with congenital profound
sensor neural hearing loss
and when we ran this uh
the sample for this patient on the other
genome
we identified two variants we identified
a frame shift variant in the gjb6 gene
and we also identified a missense
variant in the myo1a gene so the
question was
do we think that either of these
variants are related to this individual
to this
patient's hearing loss or
is one of them positive for the hearing
loss or not and so that's kind of the
the novel their assessment
process that we undergo every time we do
clinical testing
so we'll start with the gjb6 there so
gjb6 variant um is
associates to a very well known uh
hearing loss gene gjb2 it's uh
supposedly co-localizes to the cochlea
to the inner ear and might create some
plays a role in in gap junction
formation
uh we don't have sufficient
evidence to really understand what it
does and what its true role is in in the
inner ear
now it has been associated with several
different diseases based on the
literature and based on om and different
databases and it's one of
one of his disease associations is with
hydraulic ectodermal dysplasia two
miscellaneous have been identified uh
individuals with that disease
um and it seems that there's several
reports that uh support that so we're
pretty uh you know we're pretty uh
pleased with the evidence that
associated with hydraulic ectodermal
dysplasia however keep in mind that our
patient doesn't have hydraulic
ectodermal dysplasia
they presented with the non-syndromic
hearing loss
um
it's also gjp6 has also been associated
with autosomal dominant hearing loss um
there's two different reports that uh
make that suggestion uh in one report
it's a missense variant that has been
associated with autosomal dominant
hearing loss in the other it's a frame
shift variant shown here
and these two uh
however the evidence is just based off
of one family it's one report for each
one of these
and if you look closer at these variants
and use additional data we found that
these variants both are present in the
population so they're found in exact so
it's you know we
don't know if uh if this if this gene is
related to another form of dominant
hearing loss but we don't think that the
information we have based on these two
variants is sufficient to make that
assumption
now what has been established is that
gjb6 deletions large deletions has been
associated with non-syndromic hearing
loss and we've seen this figure before
earlier
we know that deletions that affect gjb6
we know that deletions that
are upstream of the gdb2
gene affect
the
transcription of gjb2 so it's not really
deletions of gjb6 that are causing gear
losses rather than the lesions
uh that lie upstream of gjb2 and affect
its expression which cause hearing loss
so
again
the
the the gene disease association with
gjb6 is not really understood and so
it becomes difficult it becomes
difficult for us to try to identify or
try to classify the variance so in this
case it's a frameshift variant the
evidence suggests that it hasn't been
reported in individuals with hearing
loss this this specific variant has been
seen in the control population although
it's a very low frequency so it's
possible that it's still causative of
something
um and because it's a frame shift we
know that it may cause a loss of
function of the of the protein
and so it will have a detrimental effect
on the protein so it you know we can't
rule it out however because we don't
know if jgb like
these variants that affect ggb6 uh
specifically affect uh cause
non-syndromic hearing loss we can't say
that this very is pathogenic for the
hearing loss as seen in our patient and
so
this there we classified as a variant of
unknown clinical significance
what about the second variant that was
seen in this individual the second
variant was a myo1a variant
miscellaneous in exon 3.
here's what we know about maya 1a in
both omen and engine reviews two very
well known databases
that curate this type of information
both associate maya 1a with
autosomal dominant deafness and you can
see that here om as well as gene reviews
so we looked at that specifically what
drove both of these databases to include
that gene disease association and all of
it is based on one uh publication
um which
found my 1a variants in a large cohort
of hearing loss individuals so we looked
at all the variants that were listed in
that publication
the publication was reported in two thou
was
published in 2003 and since then we've
had the opportunities to sequence a
large number of individuals a large
number of control populations and just
get more information information on
uncommon variants
and what we identified is that a large
number of the variants that were
identified in this patient in this
cohort
were either
found in
found and control populations making it
less likely that these variants are
positive for hearing loss uh in one case
one of the variants was found at one
percent
the majority of the variance that i
classify when i'm looking at hearing
loss
very various identified hearing loss
patients is that anything that's above
one percent i'll buy except for a few
common uh hearing loss variants they're
likely to be benign so anything above
one percent is likely to be denied
for hearing loss another variant was
seen at 3.8 percent of the population
even more so less likely to be causative
for hearing loss uh so a lot of these
variants were seen control population so
we uh you know so that makes this gene
you know the gene disease association
between my 1a and hearing loss less
likely because this is the only piece of
evidence that we have and and now we can
exclude it because these variants have
been seen at such high frequencies this
is not to say that my 1a is not positive
for hearing loss it's just given the
current evidence that we have we need
more information to know whether truly
this gene disease association exists or
not
so how did we classify the missiles
there that we identified in our patient
uh it was not reported in any other
individuals that we've uh
or in large populations uh the
computational prediction programs uh
they look at misunderstandings and and
we look at conservation and a lot of
other elements to try to understand
whether um
whether other
you know whether in this sense change is
actually pathogenic or not they didn't
provide any information to or did not
provide evidence for or against
autogenicity
so we classified this then as a variant
of unknown clinical significance
so in to summarize this case we
identified two variants
both were classified as variants of
unknown significance
and so the the report went out as an
inclusive report
now this in my opinion is
the reason it went out as an inclusive
report is because we identified two
variants and two genes that we did not
really know whether the gene disease
association existed for these genes with
hearing loss um
and it becomes not an issue of
you know the way that we classify the
variance but it becomes an issue of
whether to include these genes on
hearing loss panels we don't know enough
about these genes associated with
hearing loss uh they only add confusion
to the report they add they definitely
take time to interpret and analyze uh
sanger follow-up has to confirm all
these variants that we identify so it
just takes more time more energy more uh
greater cost to be able to go after
these virus when in essence we don't
even know if they're truly associated
with a disease
so what we did was we found that there's
a large number of hearing loss genes
that have been associated based on
evidence that was not strong that was
not compelling um and so what we went
back and did we looked at all the uh all
the genes that are hearing a lot on our
hearing loss panels as well as other
commercial laboratories
who offer hearing loss testing and we
bend the genes based on evidence into
one of these
five categories whether there was an
association
or if there was not a strong or
compelling association and the the way
we did that was we looked at the
variants that were identified in these
reports
that were identified in these genes and
whether those variants were
segregated with a disease
whether there was any functional
analysis or in vitro uh
or in vivo mouse models or animal
studies that were done to knock out the
gene and see the effect of that gene in
animals so we kind of used all that
evidence
that was available to us to kind of
either to either classify the gene as
having a strong association or a weaker
association
and when we did that we looked at 145
different genes that are available in
our panel as well as other panels and we
found that
54 of those genes
that's about 37 percent of all the genes
that we looked at did not have strong
evidence or compelling evidence
to be
called non-syndromic
hearing loss genes so we're not saying
that these 54 genes are not related to
hearing loss we're just saying that the
evidence would lead to inconclusive
reports as i've shown earlier and it
just leads to more complication and
testing and interpretation
so the idea would be to be able to
exclude these genes from future clinical
gene panels so that you're able to uh
provide a better clinical sensitivity
and clearer reports to the patient and
to the
physician
and one way to do that is there's
several is to be to for for clinical
molecular laboratories to share
information on variants as well as genes
and to share their experiences
um in trying to interpret these genes
and try to interpret these variants uh
one such effort that's uh there's
several efforts out there one such
effort is carried out by the clinical
genome resource task force uh it's
headed by it's headed by our
laboratory director here heidi reed
and
essentially the idea is that all
laboratories share the variance and
their classifications and what genes
they've classified as well as you know
the way they're looking at gene disease
associations and what they've included
on their gene panels and this will help
us
grow our
cause not knowledge database so that
we're able to better
include certain genes on on different
hearing panels whether it be hearing
loss or cardiomyopathy or any disease
area but also to
systema systematically classify variants
the same way and use data across labs to
be able to support that classification
so to summarize really quickly when
we're you know i
the our experience with clinical genetic
testing panels uh
led to some challenges both on the
technical end as well as in the
interpretive end
and it's important to really consider
both of these when when when when
approaching
uh maturation sequencing panels will try
to develop new panels when trying to add
new genes that everything is looked at
uh you know and everything is considered
you know in terms of copy number variant
detection as well as pseudogene homology
for the technical side but also you know
really
looking at genes uh and gene disease
associations critically just to assess
whether they should be included on
panels or not
so
with that i'd like to stop here and just
give an opportunity for us to have a
discussion if you have any questions
related to this or related to ngs
clinical gene panels in general
i also want to very quickly thank the uh
the organizers of the event as well as
rachel for for
and don for hosting me and allow me uh
giving me this opportunity to speak to
everyone here today
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question answer session i would like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions
you can submit questions by typing them
in the q a box which can be found by
clicking on the green q a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
and our first question is
what about using a nano string to
confirm cnv results
so uh yes i've heard of uh several
laboratories in the stream i think uh
we have i don't have any experience
personally with it but i think uh any
type of uh secondary assay that has been
validated uh it could be used for for
copy number during detection
okay so this next question it was posed
kind of differently it it reads used to
singer sequencing
will my lab have to go ngs
sequencing
uh well that i mean it all depends on
what
what kind of
testing that you offer so you know to go
to an earlier slide if you are
interested in
um
it really depends on what
kind of testing that you do so if you're
only doing single gene testing if you're
doing a handful of genes then sanger
sequencing still makes sense it still
has a fast turnaround time and it's
relatively cheaper to other
methodologies however if you're
expanding to
70 gene panels as we are doing with
hearing loss if you're expanding to the
exome which many labs are doing now
to be able to capture that is virtually
very cost ineffective and very time
consuming to do that with anger
sequencing so i think it's a
it's it depends on what the strategy of
the testing in your ladders and the
number of genes and the diseases of
course you know again if you're looking
at
a single disease that has a single
variant uh or a single gene that's
associated with disease for example
cystic fibrosis
you can get you can
do fine by just uh sequencing the cf
gene uh however if you want to do a
pulmonary panel which there's more than
50 genes including the cfg and then no
next generation sequencing would be the
way to go
all right so it looks like those were
all of the submitted questions
and we'll go ahead and wrap this up
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through november 2015.
you will receive an email from
labyrinths alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay
we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
see you next time goodbye